hey remember when Donald Trump took
classified documents out of the White
House to a private location so the FBI
raided his home and the liberal press
assailed him for weeks and the doj
threatened to prosecute him you remember
when Joe Biden called Trump's actions
unbelievably egregious
when you saw the photograph of the top
secret documents laid out on the floor
at Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or Etc
and it just uh totally irresponsible
totally irresponsible well it turns out
that Joe Biden did the exact same thing
according to our report from CBS News
approximately 10 documents were found at
Biden's private office in Washington
locked just like Trump's documents
inboxes in a closet the documents
reportedly included top secret files
designated as sensitive compartmented
information meaning that they include
highly sensitive information obtained
from intelligence sources and they've
apparently been sitting in Biden's
closet ever since he left the vice
presidency seven years ago which raises
the only way in which what Biden did was
different from what Trump did when Trump
took his classified documents he did so
as the outgoing president who has the
right to declassify whatever he wants
whenever he wants without any formal
process when Biden took his classified
documents he did so as the outgoing vice
president who doesn't have any right
whatsoever to declassify documents on
his own
did the FBI kick in Joe Biden's door
or the media accusing Biden of selling
State secrets and and getting spies
killed no not quite the authorities have
just gone ahead and collected the
documents swept the story mostly under
the rug
and moved along to look out for the next
big Trump Scandal I'm Michael Knowles
this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from moose chuckle
who says it's disappointing because I
really could have gone for a complete
government shutdown I still could that's
true I I guess that's true but the
Silver Lining and the storm cloud of
Congress getting back to business and
screwing up things for the American
people is that now with
speaker McCarthy in charge we are seeing
some very strong early signs of
conservative government which we'll get
to in one second first though if you
like me like moose chuckle over there
don't trust the way the government is
run right now to manage the economy well
and to protect your wealth and your
property you might want to check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles to 98
98 98 the current administration's New
Year's goals are to tax spend and turn a
blind eye to inflation if this is at
odds with your goals which I assume it
is and you're tired of the government
playing games with your savings and your
retirement plan then you need to get in
touch with the experts at Birch gold
today for over 5 000 years gold has
withstood inflation geopolitical turmoil
and stock market crashes now you can own
gold in a tax sheltered retirement
account Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals texted Knolls Canada
wlas to 98 98 98 to claim your free
InFocus it on gold and then talk to one
of their precious metals Specialists
with an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles Canada
wlas to 98 98.98 and protect yourself
with gold today that is Knolls to 98.98
98.
we are starting off the year right in
Congress we are starting off the year
right here at the daily wire too by the
way because the daily wire has finally
gotten a piece of technology that is
actually very old basic technology but
I've been yelling from the rooftops for
them to get it for a long time which is
we can now take your calls on the
podcasts and we are going to be doing
that today in the live show toward the
end of the show so if you are one of the
creme de La Creme Inner Circle daily
wire Plus members you can call in at
855-236-3228 and I will get to hear your
mellifluous voice in real time and we
can speak like real people which will be
really really fun if you're not a daily
wire plus member what are you doing head
on over to dailywire.com Knowles become
a member today goodness gracious great
way to start off the year here at the
daily wire and a great start to Kevin
McCarthy's speakership you know I was
probably the most vocal Defender
in the conservative media of the 20
holdouts those conservatives who would
not vote for McCarthy who are demanding
more concessions from him to make sure
that the conservatives really had a
voice in the new Republican Congress
that's good they got those concessions
they had a great fight I also pointed
out that Kevin McCarthy was considerably
more conservative than recent speakers
of the house that Republicans have had
relatively low bar that we're talking
about here when we talk about people
like John Boehner but still I said you
look at the issues Kevin McCarthy might
be the most conservative speaker that
we've had since the 1950s
well we're seeing some some good signs
right now according to an AP
Congressional reporter McCarthy is
moving ahead with with taking Adam
Schiff ilhan Omar and Eric swalwell off
of their committees
you couldn't have wished this for three
more fitting people
he has said that these people need to
get off of their committees which are
pretty significant committees the
intelligence committee Foreign Affairs
committee he says quote small well can't
get a security clearance in the private
sector I'm not going to give him a
government security clearance Schiff has
lied to the American public all these
these Democrats in particular have
proven themselves
irresponsible and not worth trusting
with this kind of serious information
Eric swalwell slept with the Chinese spy
allegedly reportedly and Adam Schiff it
was even worse frankly than swalwell
swalwell is a bloviating
bag of air atom shift though has has
been a little more nefarious than that
he has lied he's and he's lied on behalf
of really bad actors within the
executive agencies to undermine the
Trump Administration to advance the
Russia hoax to to undermine as far as
I'm concerned American self-government
and so one of the big concessions that
the conservatives wanted to get out of a
McCarthy speakership was you need to go
after the weaponization of the FBI and
the other government agencies against
conservatives and this is a great move
in that direction by taking these people
off their committees specifically by
taking shift off the committee
Kevin McCarthy is signaling that he is
going to get serious about the
weaponization of the agencies he is
going to take the bad left-wing actors
in the intelligence Community down a pag
and the first step is going to be taking
these
absolute loose cannons off of the Intel
and Foreign Affairs committee so good on
him good start to the speakership
and then you turn to Matt Gates one of
the people who is leading the charge of
the 20 holdouts against McCarthy and you
say okay well if if McCarthy seems to be
magnanimous in Victory are those 20
holdouts are they still angry as the
Republican caucus still fractured are
the are the Republicans going to be able
to get absolutely nothing done like the
liberal media told us they would Matt
Gates says it's all going to be fun
there was a tense moment late night
Friday night when Congressman Mike
Rogers expected to be the next chairman
of house armed services confronted you
you guys both serve on the armed
services committee what was that all
about and are you guys going to be able
to work together on armed services well
Mike Rogers is going to be a terrific
chairman of the armed services committee
and we share a deep commitment to our
National Defense to our men and women in
uniform and of course in a late night
moment of high drama people can have
moments of frustration but Mike Rogers
and I have a six-year productive working
relationship we're going to work
together wonderfully going forward and I
don't think there should be any
punishment or reprisal just because he
had an animated moment he has my
forgiveness and certainly is someone
who's done great things for our National
Defense and will continue to do those
great things
great answer from Gates that's a great
answer it's very magnanimous of gates
and the other conservatives as well
it's all working out just fine folks and
so regardless of this incident that got
a lot of play that Mike Rogers lunging
at Matt Gates I don't think he was
actually going to punch him in the face
but he was clearly pretty animated it
was a high intensity moment as part of
this high intensity three or four days
you had the establishment Republicans
calling the conservatives terrorists you
had the conservatives saying that
McCarthy was basically no different from
a Democrat it was it was a moment of
intense rhetoric and the libs and the
squishes they all said this means the
Republican party is over they're a mess
no
some of us as this was happening we said
this is constitutional government
inaction
this is supposed to be this is how
things are supposed to be in the
Congress
you fight you negotiate hard you get
concessions you're not supposed to just
get rubber stamped into whatever
leadership position you want and then
you move on and you come back together
after a few difficult days you come back
together you're stronger for it the the
libs still want to spread this idea that
there is historic chaos in the
Republican Congressional caucus
the historic chaos and the House of
Representatives this past week
embarrassed not only a party but an
entire nation
a small minority blocked the house from
electing a leader or even swearing in
its own members
vote after vote a would-be speaker could
not bring himself to stand aside in
favor of a colleague
yes it was only for a few days in
January
but if members of the incoming majority
party can't bring themselves to support
a new leader then one wonders what
happens when Congress faces tough
decisions on budgets taxes defense or
raising the debt ceiling actually
governing
I'm Leslie Stahl we'll be back next week
with another edition of 60 minutes
what happens when the Congressional
Republicans face real tough issues what
are they going to do I guess now they're
going to debate those issues
a prospect that strikes fear Into the
Heart of liberals like Leslie Stahl oh
no
those Republicans they were just
supposed to rubber stamp whatever the
liberal establishment wanted but now
some of them are actually debating the
issues they're making arguments they're
questioning the liberal agenda and
perhaps even impeding that agenda oh my
gosh can you imagine anything worse
these Republican congressmen if they're
willing to put up a fight on principle
and exact concessions from The
Establishment wing of their party by
golly
they might not just go along with the
whole liberal agenda oh my goodness they
might actually fight back and make
arguments oh boy we can't have any of
that
this is Congress we're not supposed to
have any debates here
now
when the government does not debate
things when they just go along blindly
into unwise imprudent sorts of policies
you get things like multi-year lockdowns
all right now if your business was
locked down for any period of time
because of covid you might be entitled
to a refund that's why you got to check
out refunds Pro right now go to
refundspro.com if you own a small to
medium-sized business that kept
employees on payroll through covid you
may have a big cash refund waiting for
you the employee retention credit is a
tax credit of up to twenty six thousand
dollars per employee right now more
businesses than ever qualify the experts
over at
refundspro.com that's plural refunds
because there's a lot of money out there
for you can help you out through the red
tape and qualify for this government
program most of their refunds are over
one hundred thousand dollars even
businesses that have received PPP funds
may be eligible there are absolutely no
fees unless you receive a refund there
is no reason not to apply if your
business experience shutdowns limited
capacity supply chain challenges reduced
Revenue due to covet you very likely
qualify
refundspro.com has already helped
thousands of businesses don't lose the
refund you're owed by missing the
deadline
get started today with a free
five-minute questionnaire at
refundspro.com that is refunds with an s
pro.com
speaking of covid speaking of
establishment propaganda
Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon was always my favorite of
the new crop of late night hosts he he
seemed to be the least
overtly hostile to conservatives the
most fun the most entertaining
certainly the most talented
Jimmy Fallon has just
play the clip
but this latest variant might be the
best
[Music]
19 has arrived it's a new strain but it
isn't the same sounds more like Elon
Musk his name
[Music]
is UB40 who sees Red Red Wine put on
your map when you're inside a facility
it could be a robot from a Star Wars
1.5 not OMG or MP3 or TCBY or an eye
chart made by a really high guy sounds
like the password of your parents Wi-Fi
1.5
[Music]
so I'm always trying to see the good in
things it's hard to see the good and
that absolutely cringe-inducing
performance
but are we are we at least now admitting
that covet is a total joke is that what
we're doing I guess that's what we're
doing now
because you don't you don't do little
song and dance routines about serious
illnesses you don't do a song and dance
routine
some people have AIDS
h-i-v and AIDS AIDS AIDS you don't you
don't see late night hosts doing that
you don't see people singing songs and
dance routines about cancer or about
about serious illnesses but they they do
now sing song and dance routines about
covid
hahaha there's another round of kovid
which is fine I think it's fine to make
light even of things that cause some
suffering and inconvenience and and even
even things that really
are quite unpleasant
but the regime the the ruling political
order locked down our country for two
and a half years over this thing they
locked down our country they said it was
so serious that we had to take
unprecedented action to destroy
businesses closed churches have our
loved ones die alone destroy your career
or kick you out of the army kick you out
of your health care job kick you out of
school
because of how serious kovid was and
then up just kidding coven
it's a joke don't you get it why aren't
you laughing with me
it reminds me of when Stephen Colbert on
his own late night show decided to do a
song and dance routine about the covet
vaccine
remember this so there's Colbert
I actually shouldn't downplay his talent
either a saying Jimmy Fallon was
obviously the most talented
you see you see Stephen Colbert's a very
good dancer he's actually a very funny
physical performer even though he's a
tedious live when he speaks
and it's Colbert they're dancing around
with people dressed up as giant syringes
which is a different kind of joke by the
way than the joke that Jimmy Fallon was
making
in a way Stephen Colbert's though
equally cringy possibly even cringier
was more justifiable because Stephen
Colbert was making light of the vaccine
everyone was nervous about the vaccine
we now know rightly so because the
vaccine was not effective in the way
that we were told it would be effective
and the vaccine was not safe in the way
that we were told it would be safe so
people had legitimate fears about it and
the establishment propaganda went into
full force to convince people oh it's
not a big deal so if you do a song and
dance routine of oh tihe it's just a
funny little vaccine don't worry it's a
shot it's no big deal that makes some
more sense
now the establishment propaganda has
become even more egregious which is that
they're telling you to laugh and giggle
about the virus that they just recently
had told you was so serious you had to
lock down your whole life and and put
your whole life on pause or worse
because of it
why is Jimmy Fallon doing this
either it means
that Jimmy Fallon is just chilling the
talking points that the powers that be
want him to show which is possible
I don't think he's some hard leftist but
he's a nice guy go along to get along
kind of guy he'll rub Donald Trump's
hair when it's when it's
funny and then he'll also sound like a
big lib when it's funny too so it could
be that or the scariest possibility
is that
Libs and conservatives actually live
according to
tally different perceptions of reality
if the libs actually believe that that
kind of performance is funny the
performance of covid or the vaccine
dance or anything like that then putting
aside our views about
a particular set of lockdown policies or
anything like that
it means that our perception of reality
is just totally different because I
there is nothing less funny there's
nothing less intentionally funny than
I've ever seen than those two
performances about coven but for the
libs they they really live in dread of
enthrall of covid and Dr fauci and they
believed all of the propaganda and all
of the nonsense and so it really might
resonate with them
that might be the scariest possibility
of all now speaking of the science
one of the men who is held up as proof
that we shouldn't always go along with
the scientific consensus he's finally
striking back this is a man named Paul
Ehrlich Paul Ehrlich is The Man Behind
the population bomb this is a man behind
the false idea that we were headed into
a a period of overpopulation in the
1960s and 70s and that this would cause
not might cause would certainly cause
Mass famine all over the world
this is a man who said that in order to
avoid the problem of overpopulation we
needed to encourage people to use
contraception and to kill their children
through abortion and potentially to
sterilize themselves and if we couldn't
convince them to do that voluntarily we
should potentially do that by force this
is a man on Whose ideas China and India
to a degree based their population
control policies that forced the
population to kill their own children
Force the one child policy in China
which they've now had to reverse because
overpopulation was a complete lie that
in India caused
Untold numbers of people to become
sterilized in order to access basic
things like food and water in the
country hideous some of the cruelest
most hideous policies that we've seen in
the last hundred years and Paul air like
was proven totally wrong and he is he is
a punch line to conservatives I I've
mentioned him many times on this show
well Paul Ehrlich is striking back
airlock says this is in response
actually to another story by 60 minutes
he says 60 Minutes Extinction story has
brought the usual right wing out in
force if I'm always wrong so so is
science since my work is always peer
reviewed including the population bomb
and I've gotten virtually every
scientific honor sure I've made some
mistakes but no basic ones
I love this defense
because this is not the defense that
Paul Ehrlich thinks that it is
he says look if I'm always wrong then so
is science
because my my work is always peer
reviewed including the population bomb
that predicted that there would be
inevitably Mass famines because of
overpopulation by the mid-1970s and
1980s
I've received every scientific honor so
if if I am wrong then science is wrong
so okay let me try to work out a little
syllogism here
if Paul Ehrlich is always wrong then so
is science
that's number one number two
Paul air like is always wrong he is he
is his big claims are just wrong
therefore
I guess science is wrong and by the way
I gave a speech on this very topic just
a couple of months ago at where was I
think I was at was I at Franciscan or
Wisconsin Lutheran University I forget I
uh Wisconsin Lutheran College I it was
one of my yaf speeches last semester you
can find it online
science is fake
I'm not saying that
I'm not making any particular Claim
about any particular scientific theory
other than I guess Paul Air likes
because the population above theory was
totally wrong he says I've never made
any basic mistakes pretty sure
predicting inevitable Mass worldwide
famines within 10 years when in fact the
opposite happened when in fact instead
of overpopulation starving everybody the
world population doubled and
malnutrition fell to an all-time low I'm
pretty sure that's a basic mistake but
regardless my claim that Paul Ehrlich
appears to be demonstrating is that the
scientific view of the world the idea
that the world is basically reducible
just to its physical elements that there
is no metaphysical level beneath the
world and that the scientific method is
sufficient for understanding the
fundament of reality if the fundament of
reality is physical that idea the idea
that has been promoted by the Scientific
Revolution is totally wrong just like
Paul air lick
speaking of controversial science
the former head of Media Matters one of
the big heads of Media Matters Parker
Malloy may have left Media Matters as
the left-wing activist organization that
putatively exists to get us all fire
that has tried to destroy my career many
times but I've always considered them to
be my unpaid publicists they always clip
out some of the really best moments of
my show so I really thank them the the
former one of the big people behind
Media Matters has apparently left is now
writing a sub stack just like all of
these people do when they leave their
jobs
uh but she had a really funny headline
she says the New York Times declares war
on lgbtq people with the higher of an
anti-trans columnist
I said oh the New York Times hired an
anti-trans columnist and is thereby
declaring war on lgbtq people who would
that columnist be
David French
she's talking about David French you may
or may not know who David French is
David French
previously was a
pretty much conservative columnist
conservative libertarian type columnist
who write wrote for conservative outlets
and then now he has become a liberal
columnist who writes for the Atlantic
and now the New York Times
the pivot in David French's career the
reason that he shifted from being a
center-right conservative person to
being a liberal person
is because he defended the transgender
agenda
yeah the the knock the reason that David
wrench has aroused the ire of pretty
much everybody on the right
is because
in a debate with so rabba Mari David
French claimed that drag queen Story
Hour is one of the blessings of liberty
at which point James Madison I think
rolled over in his grave
not only has David French defended
transgenderism he has defended
exposing little children at the public
library to these drag queen perverts who
are jiggling around for them and
twerking and doing all sorts of depraved
things that obviously should not be
tolerated or legal
that's that is the defining feature of
this man's career now I'm sure he wishes
that we're not the case it's sad that
that defines his career but it does
Define his career
and so why do I mention it because I
care about the Media Matters lady or
because I I think that David French's
literary Pursuits are particularly
interesting no I mention it as a warning
to any conservative who might want to
squish
the libs will never like you
they will never like you even if you
squish like a jellyfish they still won't
like you even if you head on over and
you disavow all of the conservatives and
you say look I might be on the right
I might be a conservative person but I'm
not like those mean evil conservatives
I'm not like Donald Trump
I'm not like the daily wire I'm not like
Michael Knowles I'm not like
insert whatever conservative person you
want no no no I'm I'm a good
conservative
I read the New York Times I'm
open-minded I totally want to redefine
marriage and let Joe Biden win the
presidency and I hell I'll even trans
the kids
please don't hate me please like me they
still won't like you
still won't like you
they view you as the enemy you will
never go far enough over to be
acceptable to them they will call you
even if the defining feature of your
career is going radically woke on the
transgender question they will still
call you anti-trans they will still call
you an lgbtq hater
just know that going in if you if you
sincerely
completely change your entire View
and you're not just trying to get an
audience and you're not just trying to
be acceptable at cocktail parties if you
if you sincerely say okay I renounce my
political beliefs I renounce my faith I
renounce my friends I renounce
everything and you maybe then you've got
a shot but if you're trying to be a CNN
Republican if you're trying to be a New
York Times conservative
almost without exception I guess rust
out that would be
a one rare kind of exception but all the
rest of them
all the rest of them will will
not be able to maintain their
conservative cred as Ross doubt that
sort of uniquely has and if you if you
just try to be acceptable to the libs
they will not accept you it's just not
going to happen speaking of weird sex
stuff
this is the most disturbing story that I
have read in weeks
if if you've got little kids listening
right now maybe just skip ahead a minute
or two
last Friday 11 people appeared before
the high court in Glasgow accused of
operating a satanic cult which abused
two young girls and a boy
who were allegedly forced to engage in
Rich witchcraft rituals and subjected to
sexual and violent abuse by members of
the group
the court heard testimony
that the two young girls and the young
boy had been forced to kill animals use
a Ouija board or a similar sort of tool
quote to call on spirits and demons in
witchcraft ceremonies the children were
then forced into performing satanic
seances including drinking blood and
eating a heart
one of the alleged girl victims was
reported to have been locked in a fridge
a freezer a microwave in an oven in an
attempt to kill her okay that's the
disturbing stuff you can you can
raise the volume back up again if you're
listening with young children obviously
and
insanely disturbing story
but the
the point of the story that is going to
be discussed if it is discussed at all
in the liberal media is that there was
this pedophile ring and they abused
children sexually
that part is actually the easiest part
to understand
it's easy for people in our modern
liberal decadent age to recognize that
that sex is a powerful motivator and
some people are perverts and and people
can commit sex crimes that part it's
disturbing to anybody with even a shred
of a conscience but it's it's at least
easy to understand
the part that's very difficult for
people to understand in our modern
liberal scientistic age
is the satanic
witchcraft
occult ritual of it all that part people
have a really hard time getting
they say look I understand how a pervert
could want to commit a sexual crime
why the hell they pull out a Ouija board
why were they doing weird witchcraft
stuff why were they calling up D that
can't be real
that doesn't
the hard part to understand isn't the
pedophile stuff it's the satanic stuff
because even the libs even the people
who are trying to normalize pedophilia I
I suppose perhaps especially the people
who are trying to normalize pedophilia
and and refer to pedophiles as minor
attracted persons and all the rest of it
they believe in pedophilia everybody
believes that exists
half of the people around today maybe
more do not believe that Satan exists
I always go back to this amazing
interview in New York Magazine in 2011 I
think it was between some young
know-nothing liberal reporter and
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia the
conservative and
somehow Heaven and Hell came up
and the Reporter Goes do you believe in
heaven and hell
and he goes yeah and she goes that's got
to be awful scary to live in a world
with hell
and he goes you know in a theatrical
whisper he says I even believe in the
devil
she goes well boy you got to be shaking
in your boots believing in the devil he
goes do you know how out of touch you
see
do you realize
that people throughout all of history
have believed in the devil
do you realize that many more
intelligent people than you or I
believe in the devil
and she didn't know what to say
I always go back to Hamlet
there are more things in Heaven and
Earth Horatio and are dreamed of in your
philosophy and I can't help but notice
when when you read these stories of the
pedo sex rings that we were all told
were total conspiracy theories until
they keep being proven again and again
and again including some of the most
prominent wealthy powerful people in the
world
I you can't call it a crazy conspiracy
theory after the Jeffrey Epstein stuff
came to light but I can't help but
notice it always seems to involve
something more than just the physical
body
you look at Jeffrey Epstein's weird pedo
Island there's this bizarre Pagan
Egyptian temple looking thing there
you look at the cases of sexual abuse in
ever in religious communities in
non-religious communities it always
seems to involve weird occult rituals
the stories one hears about this from
people who've been convicted of it
very often goes back to Satan I wonder
why that is wonder why that is
why does it always keep coming back to
the same sort of imagery maybe it's
because many more intelligent people
than you and I have believed in the
devil speaking of devilish things
and rotate the most Googled man on Earth
last year who I don't know where this
guy came from
he seemed to pop out of nowhere which
always makes me suspect always makes me
a little bit skeptical and makes people
seem suspect to me but my producers one
time listen you got to watch this guy
Andrew Tate so I did I reacted to some
of his videos and I said you know he's
saying things
that contradict the the established
liberal Dogma
so for that I guess
he ought to be applauded or at least we
ought to entertain him but he's also
saying things that seem pretty
degenerate and he isn't he a pimp
doesn't he run a weird sex online
business and that's not good that's not
conservative at all that should be that
should be discouraged
so then Andrew take gets arrested for
apparently running a criminal sex
trafficking ring
and some people on the right have rushed
to his defense
I don't I don't really know what the
defense is I mean the defense could be
he's not being arrested because he's a
sex trafficker he's being arrested
because the libs hate him yeah that
could be true I mean they let Epstein
operate with impunity for years they
don't go after the sexual criminals on
their own side
and they promote sex work as real work
so they don't sincerely believe that sex
trafficking is a problem but
nevertheless the question is did he do
these things did this guy commit crimes
and there's a video that's just come to
light of Andrew Tate bragging that his
whole business was a scam
here's maybe this is a bit bad here's
where the famous would start so it'd be
good like I had a lot of girls who
worked for me and the best was like the
ukrainians or the Russians it was
amazing because they get some guy fall
in love that they'd arranged today to
meet all this [ __ ] ah I need a visa okay
get Visa I need money for a Visa
okay how much is Visa it's 900 no but
it's not 900 because I went to the
Embassy they think I'm a risk and I need
a return flight there and back I need a
hotel I need to have spending money in
my bank account they won't let me come
how much you need all right 10 grand
booms 10 G's okay thanks wow go to the
Embassy take a picture outside the MC
Boom come back they rejected my Visa
they said we have to wait two weeks
after two weeks they'll give it to me
okay baby boom two more weeks of tips
boom boom boom boom because now we think
is good right things to get the girls
now he's spending more than ever two
weeks two weeks two weeks come
some other problem
whether it's Visa whatever whatever we
make up some [ __ ] right all these
only fans chicks can learn from you
people people watch three only fans
tutorial yeah people who people people
would say why did those girls work for
you because the girls would work for me
and at 50 because it was 50 50 would
make millions per month if they work for
themselves they make nothing I was the
best in the
game me and I had a whole team of staff
now one thing you always have to ask
yourself with online self-help Guru
promoter guys like this is are they
telling the truth and we have no reason
to believe that Andrew Tate is telling
the truth because the thing that he is
talking about is how he's a liar
so if you present yourself in public as
a liar then
I can't believe you in fact I can't even
believe any specific claim of you lying
and scamming because you might though
you are dishonest in other ways and
claiming to be dishonest you you may
actually be being uh truthful or
dishonest about being dishonest you see
how it gets very confusing but but if
this part is true
and he's the best in the effing game and
I'm scamming all these guys then isn't
that fraud
isn't that a crime
isn't that should we really be surprised
that you get arrested
and even if you say well there's plenty
of scammers plenty of fraudsters plenty
of pimps out there they don't get
attacked by the liberal regime right but
you're you've made a name for yourself
attacking all these liberal orthodoxies
meanwhile you're bragging about all the
crimes that you're committing so you're
just showing your neck to your enemies
not very good stuff in any case none of
this particularly virtuous or worth
emulating I strongly suspect
we are going to be moving on to calls
I'm very very excited we've finally got
the technology we finally now have
technology from the 1970s to receive
your calls live and I get to talk to you
and hear your beautiful dulcer tones
live of course you have to be a daily
wire plus member right now so you got to
call
1-855-236-3228 if you're not a daily
wire plus member what are you doing if
your daily wire plus member you get so
much stuff you get discounts in the
merch store you get the show ad free so
right now become a daily wire plus
member okay it enhances your Michael
Knowles show listening experience by
removing the ads and you get other shows
like the Ben Shapiro show the Matt Walsh
show morning wire and more all without
ads by the way your membership also gets
you tons of other ad-free content from
yours truly such as choosing death such
as fauci unmasked ad-free it is the word
of the day it might just be the last
time you have to hear me say it because
there won't be any more at right now you
can use code Knowles kwles to get two
months free on all annual plans go to
dailywire.com Knowles to become a member
and get this show and so many others ad
free dailywire.com slash Knowles
Mr Davies do we have callers on the line
excellent all right let's turn first to
Dean from Wisconsin Dean you are on the
line
good morning Michael thanks for taking
my call uh I just was going to point out
in our diocese on the day that Pope
Benedict died it was also the day that
our diocese implemented a ban on the
celebration of the Latin mass in the
extraordinary form so they're saying oh
you can use Novus ordos but not the old
right Latin Mass anymore
um my question you might not have the
specific answer to this maybe you can
bring on an expert in the members block
but can each Pope just flip-flop on this
issue or does some sort of a decree need
to come down from the Vatican saying the
Latin Mass may be celebrated or may not
be obviously our diocese has had quite a
difficult reaction to all this coming
into play so I appreciate your thoughts
Michael and I'm sure you share the same
uh sadness regarding the Latin Mass
going away well Dean first of all I have
to say I find your lack of faith
disturbing not about your faith faith in
our Lord Jesus Christ and your
membership in the Holy Catholic church
but your lack of faith in me that you
think I have to bring an expert on to
the member block come on man uh though
probably I should uh in the short answer
your question is
practically speaking yes the popes can
flip-flop on this question now it's more
complicated than that because as far as
I can tell
uh Pope Pius the fifth gives us the
right to the Latin mass in perpetuity as
far as I'm concerned in my limited
knowledge again I'm not a doctor of the
church I'm not a theologian people
people don't ask my opinion on these
things but this is the mass of the ages
that has existed for basically the
entire history of the church and the the
radical liturgical reform which it may
have had good intentions maybe it didn't
but in any case it led to a deformation
of the Liturgy in the late 1960s and
into the early 1970s it it did not
achieve any of the things that it was
intended to achieve
it did not increase participation it did
not bring the youths back to the mass by
bringing in all sorts of electric
guitars or whatever and so what what
Pope Benedict did not being a total
conservative not being a total Trad but
not being a lib either is he he tried to
in the spirit of tradition to to reform
the reform and to bring that back and uh
then it was later on suppressed by uh
Pope Francis unfortunately but there
were still places for it there were
still uh Priestly the Priestly
fraternity of Saint Peter the Institute
of Christ the King there were some
Diocesan Latin Masses depending on on uh
which diocese you're in so yeah I
suppose we just have to pray that uh
that the the Lord will bring back this
very beautiful Reverend uh the highest
form of prayer which is the Holy Mass in
a proper liturgy and it reminds me of an
important phrase Lexa Randi Lex credenti
Lex viveendy you know the the way that
we worship
is going to affect the way that we
believe it's not just the other way
around it's not just the way we believe
it's going to affect the way we worship
the way we worship is going to affect
the way we believe and the way that we
live our lives because we're incarnate
beings in time and space and I do have
faith though that that it will all work
out in the end because to quote Hillary
bellock he says that he he is forced to
Believe As I Am by faith that the
Catholic Church really is divinely
instituted but a good evidence for its
Divine institution to non-believers is
that no other institution conducted with
such navish imbecility would have lasted
a fortnight so keep the faith Dean good
to hear from you next up is Mark from
Nashville
Mark you're on the air
hey Michael long time listener first
time caller uh I don't know if you've
heard about this story about the
government trying to ban gas stoves for
safety do you think it's more likely
that it is actually for safety or so
that we can continue shipping all of our
natural gas overseas to Europe in an
effort to uh sanction Russia
Mark since you phrased the question that
way I think I know which which angle
you're coming at this from I had just
seen the headline yesterday that all of
a sudden now I think it was in
California people are claiming gas
stoves are terrible and I I find when I
cook gas stoves are much better to cook
on than electric stoves I've had both I
grew up with an electric stove since
then I've had some gas stoves it's much
better to cook on the gas so you're
suggesting
you think that the the the big push now
against the gas stoves is that
the the powers that be in in Commerce
and in the government
basically just want to export more of
that gas
well it's obviously for safety no of
course of course they just want to
export the gas to Europe to try and
stick it to Russia and to I guess
demoralize us it started with the shower
heads and now gas stoves they're so
effective they're so great and now they
want to ban them just like those high
flow shower heads they were so great now
funny you mentioned this because I I
always felt this way with the light
bulbs we were told you you had to get
rid of incandescent light bulbs and use
those hideous fluorescent or LED things
because they're better for the sun
monster so that we don't get killed in
global warming or whatever mother Gaia
will be happier if we replace our
beautiful warm light with some hideous
flashing light and and for a while it
was illegal don't forget Congress banned
those light bulbs and then Michelle
Bachmann great great accomplishment by
Congress Lady Michelle Bachmann she
comes in and she says no you get you get
the light bulb Freedom of Choice act and
so I don't know I mean I just saw the
headline you're actually giving me a
more interesting idea on it than any
first reaction I had but I wouldn't be
terribly surprised because when when you
see legislation coming down the pike it
rarely happens by accident and it rarely
happens for a purely abstract reason
very often there are moneyed interests
and Powerful interests behind pushing
every piece of legislation so I keep an
open mind on your theory Mark before we
go let's get to Brian from New Hampshire
Ryan what's going on
Mr Knowles it is your favorite resident
bass player in the chat slot my base it
is what's going on man oh I'm so glad to
hear your voice live I I'm a big fan of
your comments and your music but great
to hear you live what's up how can I
help you thank you thank you so I kind
of had a hard time trying to pick out a
topic to discuss and I was actually
going to call Ben about this but I could
never get through so I guess uh the
question I will have is uh how can we be
sure to hold politicians more
accountable for their actions as it
seems like the current methods that we
have whether it be
um asking our congressmen to reach out
to uh the senate or
um basically just like everybody
standing on the line standing on the
Lawns and protesting uh doesn't seem to
be quite as effective and basically at
the same time the Storm Troopers will
come in and arrest anybody who is
protesting the non-lefts right
um or so
do you have any suggestions for people
who would like to hold their their
people their uh Senators their uh House
Representatives more accountable uh I
would have almost thought like gather a
group of people and actually go into the
building not like January 6th like here
we go here comes the horn hat
it's not like the whole NF guy but um
but I mean like go in just like politely
say the secretary hey we'd like to speak
with our governor and like almost like
an in-person confrontation yeah I I I
don't know that that is going to be
terribly effective because what that
will do is that will cause your
representative to view you as an enemy
if you're physically aggressive in that
way that that would be an escalation
that I just don't I'm not opposed to it
in principle I just think and I know I
know that you're not suggesting anything
violent you're suggesting being very
polite but I just think the reaction to
that will not be to say okay let me hear
out the concerns of these people I don't
think that's really going to work I do
think that
uh phone calls and things like boycotts
actually work a lot better than most
people believe that they do this is how
Media Matters operated for years and
years and years that what Media Matters
would do is they clip out some little
bit that either I said or any other
conservative
figure media host and then they would
get their list of 20 to 100 people to
call a company and say you need to pull
your sponsorship from this person it's
not a lot of people we're talking often
like 20 people but when you are that
secretary and you're hearing that it
doesn't come to you as a physical threat
so that you're reacting very strongly
against these people but but it it you
do perceive that as a brand threat and
so you you will take that more seriously
but but more importantly than all that
the way that you get your government to
be more responsive is you you need
structural change it's not just the
individuals very often the individuals
don't have very much power the problem
is
one problem in this regard is that the
Congress for instance just delegated a
lot of its power away to executive
agencies that don't need to answer the
phone when you call and so the Congress
can throw its hands in the air and say
listen I didn't do anything the the
Congress because of the rules instituted
under Nancy Pelosi did not have a lot of
ability to to introduce amendments on
the floor of the house or to recall a
speaker if the speaker was wielding too
much power in an unaccountable way or to
stop the debt ceiling from being waste
or any of these other issues and so I
mentioned the specific examples because
those 20 hold out conservatives the
other day who deprived McCarthy of the
speakership for three three or four days
they exacted a lot of concessions that
are structural they're not political
issues per se they're meta-political
issues there there are issues about how
politics is conducted one issue in this
regard would be the border wall or
immigration enforcement it's sort of a
political issue but it's really a
metapolitical issue because it's about
who comes into the country and then who
is going to participate in the Republic
that's where the change has to take
place if we keep fighting it on these
little individual issues or or only
putting lawn signs in our yard
got to put the lawn sign out there but
you've got to do more than that that's
not going to give you the kind of
significant change that you want you've
gotta you've got to take on the issue a
level above not just about politics but
the politics of politics excellent here
from you excellent question you know the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it become a member and
use code Knolls Canada w-l-e-s at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]